Vous êtes avertis, vous avez vu le titre, vous pourrez pas pleurer... euh..
près de mon torse, hein.
Ni près de mon mollet.
*musique de L dans Death Note en arrière-plan* Aujourd'hui on est sur Captured.
C'est un jeu dont le scénario suit le même principe que Saw on se réveille dans un endroit qu'on ne connaît pas.
C'est hardcore, c'est dégeulasse.
Il y a plusieurs pieces et il faut à chaque fois réussir une épreuve pour atteindre la pièce d'après.
C'est parti, c'est en Anglais, mais des sous-titres s’afficheront pour que vous puissiez comprendre (Comme là quoi XD .).
C'est parti, c'est en Anglais,
Vivons l'experience ensemble.
N'ayez pas peur, je suis là.
Ok, cinématique.
C'est le réveil, je suppose.
Oui.
Que ce qu'il y a autour ? *signe de faiblesse*
Rien, juste une porte. *voix rassuré*
OK. Allez, on se lève madame ! *bruit agaçant*
Bonjour...
Oui
*Exaspération*
Ok...
*Désespoir*
*Désespoir#2*
OKKKK !!
Merci le monsieur du haut-parleur
C'est très agréable de se réveiller dans ce putain d'endroit dégueulasse
Faut qu'on trouve un levier, il a dit ou une clé
Je sais pas peut être que c'était un piège
Ok, on peut prendre des choses et les envoyer ! *bruit de palette qui se pète*
OH !
Et si il n'y avait pas un levier dans cette palette ?
Une boîte à Kapla uniquement, excellent !
Ah, bah ! Un peu d'humour dans une situation comme ça, ça ne fait jamais de mal, hein ?
On ne va pas se mentir, hen ?
Là y'a quoi ? Y'a des tasses, des bouteilllles...
Pas de levier, AH ! P't'être derrière ça...
*Brisure de bouteille*
*Réaction **Too late*
Ah, putain !
Rien derrière ça, rien non plus..
Là , il y a la porte
Ah c'est fermée c'est la porte par laquelle nous a amené ici
C'est très bien ça ! Là,
Là...
J'vois rien . Ah j'crois que j'ai trouvé
Oui ok
Allez on prend des forces et on y va
Il y avait une grande soirée ici la veille y avait apparemment
Alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans cette nouvelle pièce ?
P*tain
Nan nan
Non non
AAAH
Faut pas qu'je parle . Faut qu'je sois silencieux
J'passe dans cette pièce direct j'm'en bat les co***les
J'passe dans l'autre pièce tiens j'm'en bat les co***les
What the fuck ? *Squeezie stressé*
wOOOOOOOOO AAAH
COMMENT J'FAIS J'PRENDS LA CAISSE J'LUI ENVOIE DANS LA GUEULE !!!
Comment j'fais j'prends la cage et je lui envoie dans la g**ule
Faut que j'coupe la cage en 2 plutôt que d'me couper la chair c deja mieux, peut être qu'il est bois vivant (Ca ne veut rien dire XD .).
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAh
Je cours (x?)
Une assiette Naaaan...
Fils de p*** (x6)
Y'a pas un levier un levier ?
Oui
Ça a ouvert quoi ? Ça vas-y j'y vais
AAAAAh
Il me suit pas c'est bon
*Squeezie se calme*
Ah p*tain
Ah ok ?!
Donc y'a un levier qui va ouvrir cette putain d'porte dans lequel euuh euh...
"The butcher" on va l'appeler va nous rejoindre
Donc quand on va activer ce levier là une partie de cette grille va s'ouvrir
Pour qu'on puisse accéder au deuxième levier
Sauf que cette porte la va s'ouvrir aussi donc le "Butcher" va venir s'occuper de nous
C'est parti
'taiiiiiiin
Oh j'ai esquivé son coup, oh il vise très très mal bah il es aveugle c'est pas pour rien mon gars.
Allez vite vite vite vite vite
C'est bon je l'ai fait (x6)
Y'a un deuxième homme dans la pièce
UUUUUUUUUUUUUUURGH
Le mec en plus il a dit que c’était chiant à faire tourner ces trucs de merde
Est-ce qu'il y'a a votre avis... Attends
L'autre se repère aux bruits
Le (pro)bleme c'est qu'on va activer le levier pour pouvoir faire ça
Lui il va rentrer . Donc faudrait peut-être l’attirer ailleurs
Grâce à j'sais pas
Ça peut faire du bruit si on l'envoie loin ?
j'suis en total panique j'me pisse dessus y'a y'a euh au revoir
Est-ce qu'il y a pas un truc qui fait assez d'bruits si des pots cassés
Comme ça il ira réparer les pots cassés
Jeu de mot : l'expression pot cassé compris
Let's go hein on a pas le choix
Ça a marché mec ça a marché !
AAAH (Le cri le plus viril de 2016 XD.).
Oh non ça a bien marché, faut lancer les objets comme ça il va
Oh mec c'est le jeu plus angoissant du monde
OK , nous y revoilà j'ai réussi en m'enfuyant
à ramener une deuxième bouteille comme ça on aura deux trucs pour
pour faire du bruit. Le problème c'est que tout à l'heure il a été
distrait pendant suffisamment de temps pour que j'atteigne seulement la moitié du truc
Donc il faut 6 objets au total
On a 2 cages hautes, 2 bouteilles, 2 pots . On peut s'en sortir
La quatrième fois ou il nous tape il nous tue
Donc on a que 3 chances
Ça va être chaud mec
Ok
Il arrive WAAAA il s'est foiré il est nul AAAAh
Mais arrête moi je m'en bat les co****** mec j'suis désolé YOLO égoïste m'au revoir
Ah ça le rend fou oh non
Il va mourir oh mec j'suis désolé
Oh mec j'suis désolé j'pouvais pas
J'sais pas si tu souffres ou t'essaye d'imiter Sangoku qui se transforme en Super Saiyen là
Désolé désolé j'suis désolé j'suis désolé j'pouvais rien faire j'suis désolé je m'casse
J'ai cédé à la pression comme une merde
Non mais il est trop violent le boucher
Et la j'vais sortir la douille que l'égoïste dans les films d'horreur
Sort à chaque fois.
"Oui mais si ça se trouve j'aurais réussi c’était un mensonge ça lui écrasait quand même le crane !"
Bon on arrive dans quoi là ?
Dans une pièce sombre
Ah il y a un truc a faire avec cette prise encore c'est sa
Je suis en train de culpabiliser de ouf
Si ça se trouve vous avez envie de m'insulter
Ouais mais la c'est moi qui suis au commande vous avez pas le droit
Un peu de compassion s'il-vous-plait soyez indulgents.
Alors sa c'est sous cage
Qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
Un bouton blanc un bouton noir. Des corps blanc des corps noir.
A+B
Noir blanc blanc noir blanc noir noir blanc
Ameno
Du coup on a accès a sa
P*tain mais je.... C'est horrible ce système là
Allez ouvre la porte
mec vous avez le temps qu'on a mit en fait
Tout à l'heure il nous restait 1000 tours à faire
Pour en branchez n'en serait ce qu'une, euh c'est impossible
Je suis sur que 100/100 des gens qui ont fait une vidéo sur ce jeu ont foirer et si ce n'est pas le cas
Je m'abonne a la chaine de celui qui a reussi. Ne faites pas tous une vidéo sur ce jeux demain
dans quoi on est là pourquoi pourquoi et ça
bouge  les draps ? c'est des fantomes la dessous c'est quoi ce délire
Ah j'aime pas quand sa fait ça
Ah j'aime pas quand ça fait ça!
Oh il y a un mec la dessous
Ah un moment ça va clignoter et il y aurat plus de draps ça sera que des mecs!
Ah un moment ça va clignoter et il n'y aura plus de draps ce sera que des mecs
Bon attend on a 3 pots ils sont pas la pour rien
Bon attend on a 3 pots ils ne sont pas la pour rien
Il y a des fantomes, il y a une cajotte, il y a des mecs morts derrière encore.
Et il y a une flèche la qui va dans se sens la
Et il y a 3 boutons blanc
Faut commencer celui la d'après la flêche
Celui la ensuite ça part et on arrive la bas
donc là on en a combien
1,2 ce truc la 3,4,5
Il y en a 5 avant la limitation de la flêche qui est la
donc 5
Ok
Ensuite il y a la limitation de la flêche qui est la. Ça fait 1.2.3.4.5.6.7
Je sais pas un peu près
Et ensuite il y a les corps + tous ces trucs la pour ce dernier bouton
Donc il y a 5 corps + 6.7.8.9.10.11.12 objets
YEAH
On est passer p*tain alors attend ça a ouvert le fameux levier je veux juste plus jamais revoir le mec à la machette s'il-vous-plait je vous en supplie
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
Mais le mec il était sous un drap. Mais p*tain, ma prière n'a pas été exaucé
c'est bon j'me casse(*5). J'ai réussi à le distraire avec un pot cassé
Ah p*tain mais j'en ai marre que ce jeux soit fort
c'est bon
Mais le jeu mon gars
Et bas p*tain n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a bien fait peur
Bon c'est le même mecanisme qui a fait le succès d'un outlast
Finalement c'est un mec qui peut te péter la gueule et faut le fuir à tout prie
Mais ça met vraiment dans l'ambiance cette espèce de voix qui sort du haut parleur et qui dit "tu vas mourir"
Ouais je suis le la VF du méchant dans saw
Et puis ta ces p*tain de roue a tourner qui fait un max de bruit alors que tu sais que l'autre est attiré par le bruit
Donc ça te fous encore plus mal de la tourner mais t'a envie de sauver le gars qui vas se faire .... Ohlalal
Bien bravo vous venez de regarder une vidéo sur le jeux le plus terrifiant auquel on ait jouer
Allez merci d'avoir regardé on se retrouve dans une prochaine vidéo sur un jeu beaucoup plus fun
Tchao tous... le monde vous savez se que j'allais dire